it's hard to believe it won't be long
before the kids will be back to school
as summer break is drawing to a close i
know the kids don't like hearing that
but not before the completion of the las
vegas clark county library district
summer
challenge coloring and art contest rolls
off the tongue shannon harrington is
here to tell us more about it uh your
big summer challenge is just wrapping up
right tell us about that what is that
it's so awesome so this summer challenge
is it's really meant to engage kids and
this year for the first time ever adults
as well
it's so cool and i know i'm a reader
because my parents are readers and so
you know lead by example right and so
it's really neat you can enter in you
can actually enter in now it doesn't
still a few days
later you still win great prizes um but
it's meant to really engage kids over
the summer so that teachers don't have
to start from scratch when they go back
to school right so you can go into any
of our libraries to do it and it's
really just an awesome program with
activities and reading goals and just to
win great prizes all summer so if you
jumped in today what would you need to
do you would want to read a certain
amount of hours
minutes that lead up to hours and do a
certain number of activities that's
going to the library to attend a program
or really you know going and taking a
walk up maybe right not now
but you could absolutely like cloud
watch do do a whole do art do
do the coloring contest do all kinds of
cool stuff the coloring contest is part
of it is that right that is correct okay
and tell us about that and how it works
because you want me to kind of
participate i i would love for you to do
that all right
we could take your entry back and we'll
and you in i can promise you i won't win
but yes
so the coloring art contest is part of
the theme this year we're taking the a
in steam which is such an important part
they are part of steam and so what you
can do is go into any of our branches
and pick up a coloring
form and then you um want to use any of
your favorite books that you read this
summer and translate that into art and
we've had so many amazing entries so
anything that you really that really
resonated with you we would love to see
you transform it into art and color in
the robots and that's our our mascot
this summer so and to turn it into your
library by july 31st and you're entered
into a blick art uh card okay so what am
i going to actually try to draw well
okay so i've i brought a shark book okay
and i i thought he's pretty easy he's
got a cool you can do that and that
one's pretty that's not a bad one
bob shay's wonderful we just had him at
the library and he said it's all about
shapes okay so i challenge you right and
i like that you chose for me a
children's book that's right about my
speed okay so i'm going to go over to
this uh easel over here
and draw a shark my best shark which you
know i'm not a fan of the sharks because
of san jose but for this i will do it
for this purpose i'm going to just try
to do my own here
do you do whatever you'd like uh i've
already messed it up okay but i'm going
to do that for the teeth hey that's nice
i like it
it looks like
it doesn't look like a shark at all but
that seat
but it's a t
put the little arms right there yeah
okay there we turned it into kind of a
dinosaur yeah
you think i got a chance
i can win this thing you could
absolutely
this is why i don't win pictionary too
but you've had a lot of people already
submit entries right that's correct yeah
over
and those and how will you announce the
winners so we're going to announce the
winners next week um we're going to have
different programs at all of our
branches and we're going to have a
viewing essentially so we're going to
have all of our artwork up in our
libraries so that everybody can kind of
see what their neighbors have done in
their communities and we're going to
some of our libraries are going to have
receptions some will have different
programs and everybody can come and see
what their community has done all right
really briefly your website so people
can get more information lvcc
lvccld.org shanna thanks so much for
being here appreciate it thanks for like
not ripping on my side mercedes